- Après plusieurs journées
ils arrivent enfin dans
la cape e e américaine.
Ces migrants hispaniques
qui sont entrés par l'Armimimims
par les autorités locales.
Ici, ils sont plus d'une
centaine, en provenance
juste devant la résidence de
fonction de la vice-présidente
Kamala Harris.
"La seule destinatio, , , , , ,t
ce migrant, c'etait Washington."
acacacré pied de nez politique
de la part du gouverneur
républicain du Texas,
"Une crise causée par
qui laisserait rentrer
trop de migran
Refusant de gérer le flot
de migrants sur son territoire,
quatre mois, à envoyer presqueqs
remplis dans des villes
démocrates com
New York, où 12 000 migrants ont
été relocalisés, mais aussi
au Massachusetts...
ainsi qu'à Chicago.
"Ils nous envoient ces migrants
sans nous prévenir, dit
"Le gouverneur du Texas,
dit la paiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiat
que créer le chaos avec
cette mascarade politique.
Pour juguler la crise,
la mairesse de Washington vients
de dollars, un bureau d'accueil
pour les migs.s.s.
Afin de s'assurer que le f
de migrants ne cause pas trop
de problèmes pour les services
de la ananananananananananananat
l'organisme accueille
les migrants depuis quelques
semaines, pense que le chemin
de certains d'entre eux,
n'est pas terminé.
"Certains, dit-elle,
vont continuer leur route
vers le Canada, car ils ont été
traumatisés en, , , , , , , , ,e
de Washington, des bénévolesson.
NADIA TIBARI, bénévole
- Tout ce qu'ils font, c'est
pour une meilleure vie pour
des montagnes, des rivières.
Des parc... ils on
des parcours très difficiles.
Croyez-moi.
- Clau
Elle va héberger sa nièce,
qui vient tout juste diviviver
du Texas. Un cas plus facile à
régler, mais pour des dizainesi,
c'est loin d'être termin